we begin in afghanistan where a taliban
spokesman says the group will not extend
the deadline for the withdrawal of
western forces the armed group has
warned of consequences if u.s and allied
forces do not withdraw by the august
31st deadline thousands of troops are
deployed in kabul to evacuate their
citizens and vulnerable afghans there
have been chaotic and desperate scenes
at the airport over the last week and at
least 20 people have been killed the u.s
president says the pace of evacuations
is accelerating he hopes not to extend
the deadline but he hasn't ruled it out
and as attention focuses on the
evacuation efforts the world health
organization is warning of a wider
humanitarian crisis it says 500 tons of
critical medical supplies are stuck in
the uae because of the holdup at kabul
airports meanwhile on the ground the
taliban says it has sent fighters to
panshire to counter resistance fighters
let's get more now from charlotte bellas
she begins our coverage with this
reports on the situation at kabul
airport
we're at the north gate of kabul
international airport this is where most
people ask to come to and in recent days
it has been closed because of what the
us says is security threats from isil
but for most people here the biggest
threat is dehydration is a stampede and
as constant gunfire to actually get to
this point they have to run the gauntlet
first we moved through taliban special
forces they're known as the badri 313
and they control the perimeter of the
airport if you can get past them and
convince them that you deserve to be
able to get to this point and get on a
flight out on one of these evacuation
flights then you enter a zone which is
held by afghan forces some of the last
afghan forces in the country they are
called the 01s and the o2s they are
funded by the cia and they have come to
this area as a bridge between the
taliban and the american they are also
doing checks and holding security and
essentially what is a no-man's land once
you get past them you end up where we
are now which has no security forces
around and is just
thousands of people gathering waiting
and being overlooked by western security
forces who essentially hold the key to
the gate and will decide whether these
people leave the country or do not
well we have two correspondents
reporting on the tension over a possible
extension of the deadline to withdraw
nato forces nadine baba will have the
uk's response on that from london first
though let's head to rob mcbride he's in
the afghan capital for us rob the
taliban then saying there will be no
extension to that deadline is august
31st then they want the foreign troops
out
that's right and warning of consequences
but it really remains to be seen what
consequences are they talking about and
at this stage what action would they be
prepared to take i mean you you have to
ask you know whose deadline is this
anyway it does seem to be something of a
movable feast originally the deadline
was set at may the first for the
withdrawal of u.s troops and nato forces
that was under the agreement reached
between the trump administration with
the taliban last year then in april of
this year president joe biden pushed it
back famously to the symbolic date of
september the 11th then last month he
brought it forward again to august
august the 31st so this august the 31st
date was set by biden in theory he can
now unset it the taliban doesn't like it
they say this is breaks with the
agreement that they signed last year but
the americans say well the taliban has
already broken that agreement in in any
case uh and it's difficult to see
what the taliban would do if it's done
just a few days past uh august the 31st
because as far as the americans are
concerned they can probably still get
everyone out before september the 11th
and i think at this point that the
taliban has a lot of other concerns more
pressing concerns as it tries to take
over and run a country rather than
continuing to have a scrap with the
americans so it'll talk tough i think
it'll talk about consequences i don't
really know what those consequences are
likely to be they may well turn out to
be very little meanwhile at the airport
itself we know that uh that chaos has
continued i think everyone wants to see
an end to that it's in everybody's
benefit
the us especially to see this nightmare
over but also as far as the taliban are
concerned they want an end to that and
in the meantime we do have now this
announcement from the world health
organization that
the
we could be using the arrival and
departure of these aircrafts more
intelligently because of course they
take various they full up fill up with
civilians or people from different
nationalities out of kabul but largely
arrive empty so why not put emergency
relief supplies on those planes for what
is a growing humanitarian
needs here in afghanistan in particular
this 500 tons
of medical supplies that the who says is
sitting in dubai which empty planes
could be bringing here into kabul
okay rob mcbride there bringing us up to
date from cardboard rob thank you
well the uk defense secretary ben
wallace says british troops will leave
afghanistan alongside u.s forces he says
it's unrealistic for them to stay any
longer g7 leaders are meeting on tuesday
to discuss coordination on the
evacuation process nadine baba is live
for us in london the demon the uk then
saying it will leave alongside the
americans
does that mean they're aiming for an
august 31st pull out too
well not quite hala what they're saying
is that they can't do things on their
own but they're really hoping that the
americans will actually give them uh at
least a few days more to get people out
of afghanistan on monday the uk's armed
forces minister uh james hippie has said
that the uk's got more than 6 000
individuals out of afghanistan in a week
but it still wants to evacuate thousands
more he says the focus is on getting
1800 uk passport holders out of the
country as well as uh
2275 people who are on
what's called the afghan relocations and
assistance policy
list now he says there are still names
being added to the list all the time as
people make make the uk authorities
aware that they need to get out but he
says that um it will be up to prime
minister boris johnson to try to
persuade president biden for some more
time in that virtual g7 meeting on
tuesday well the uk's defense minister
ben wallace is saying that um once the 6
000 or so us personnel are withdrawn
from kabul airport that really will make
it impossible for british forces to do
anything more
i don't think there is any likelihood on
staying on after the united states if
their timetable extends even by a day or
two then that will give us a day or two
more to evacuate people because we are
really down to hours now not weeks and
we have to
make sure we exploit every minute to get
people out
so hours not weeks as ben wallace says
suggests that um they're not optimistic
of getting
any more than perhaps a couple of days
extension uh the uk government has also
made it clear that the taliban will be
involved in any decision and that will
be they will be seeking the taliban's um
approval we've heard from robin kabul
what the taliban is saying they're
saying it's a firm no but we've also
heard that that might actually shift in
the coming days
okay nadeem baba they're giving us the
latest from london nadine thank you
nataratullah huckball is a writer and
political analyst he says the leader of
the anti-taliban force wants a
democratic government that's accepted by
all afghans
as we
had some information from the
persons close to ahmad masood that he
suggested and asked the taliban when if
he joined the taliban and he they are
working and coexisting
the local authorities from the panchayat
valley should be chosen and taken from
the panchayat valley and not from the
other provinces to be brought to panshir
and to
run the government in puncher this is
the first option the second is that the
coming and newly reforming government of
the taliban there should be
a stake for the ahmad mussoon his
supporter and also one of the
statement that he made is that that he
is trying to form a government that is
not basically
islamic and he wants to make a
democratic government that is
acceptable and that is the demand of
avranz as he says in the international
community and he doesn't want to
afghanistan be isolated and not
recognized by
international community but one thing to
remember that panchayat valley is
already
enclaved by the taliban forces from four
sides from badakhshan from baghlan
province from kabul
uh
from
kapisa from either side it is enclaved
of the taliban and it is very hard for
ahmad masood and his supporter to
defend as his
father did in 1996 until 2001 and that
situation and now is a little bit
different and it is hard to be resisted
china says it's closely following
developments in afghanistan its foreign
ministry held a news conference earlier
and said most chinese nationals have
safely returned home the government says
it's prepared to work with the taliban
we hope afghanistan can form an
inclusive and open government which
adopts a foreign and domestic policy
that's prudent and moderate we hope
it'll echo the will of the people and
international community
russian president vladimir putin is
warning about the threat of isil in
afghanistan he spoke to central asian
leaders at a virtual summit and
expressed concern that the group was
still active and could gain a foothold
the leaders agreed to coordinate and
secure their borders
iran says it welcomes a peaceful
transfer of power in afghanistan the
foreign ministry spokesman called for
the formation of an inclusive national
government
the occupation was not a solution to
afghanistan's problems the only solution
is to negotiate between all parties to
achieve a comprehensive peace in
afghanistan
we call for respecting the rights of all
nationalities and women and the
preservation of historical places we
welcome the peaceful transfer of power
in afghanistan and the formation of a
comprehensive national government
representing all afghan parties the
taliban is considered a part of the
future of afghanistan